well naftali bennett is traveling to
egypt in the first official visit by an
israeli prime minister in a decade he's
met president abdel fattah al-sisi for
talks in a resort city on the sinai
peninsula let's bring in harry fawcett
he's across this forest from west
jerusalem harry this is obviously a
significant meeting for a very important
relationship plenty for the two men to
talk about so what's likely to be top of
the agenda today
well yes this was an invitation that was
given
through the egyptian intelligence chief
from
president sisi during that intelligence
chief's visit to jerusalem
last month
and it is one which has seen the
egyptians roll out the red carpet or
more accurately the israeli flag
there are pictures of the two men
sitting together nathalie bennett in
front of an israeli flag unlike uh what
took place 10 years ago with benjamin
netanyahu there's obviously a real
effort here from the egyptians
to show that they are trying to build on
and cement this relationship in a more
public way than usual there's some
analysis here that that is because they
want to demonstrate to the americans
they're concerned potentially about
changes in the foreign policy towards
egypt from the biden administration
egypt is the second biggest recipient of
u.s
military aid in the world so being
friendly with the biggest recipient in
this public way presumably makes sense
on that front the egyptians also talking
about regional developments uh
speculation here that will include the
situation with iran but almost certainly
there will be a great deal of focus on
the situation in gaza egypt
does mediate between the egyptians
between the israelis rather and hamas
and the other fighting factions within
gaza it was crucial in bringing an end
to the fighting
in may uh the the security situation is
starting to tick up again slightly in
gaza with the uh the still
going manhunt for the remaining two six
prisoners uh the palestinian islamic
jihad five of them
from that uh that faction and there have
been rockets fired out of gaza in recent
days israeli air strikes as well
at a time when the israeli foreign
minister yai lapid is talking about a
new policy towards gaza egypt very much
crucial in any changes on that front as
well so those are the sorts of things
that will be talked about uh but a lot
of it is as well as about a public show
that this relationship is is sort of
alive in kicking and already we've seen
some other uh
things happening as a result of that the
egyptian national airline will be
running for flight today to tel aviv a
week rather to tel aviv from next month
and there have been tourist restrictions
lifted for more israelis to go into the
sinai peninsula as well so a couple of
concrete achievements being announced
already
harry force up there following that
meeting for us from west jerusalem thank
you harry